ok on est sur le spot numéro 2 de la
journée donc on va voir ce qu'il y a ici
c'est un tout petit ruisseau qui paye
pas de mine mais je vous assure qu'on va
trouver des choses et on en a déjà
trouvé on est encore en compagnie de Wim
De Danis et de Quentin et on va aller
dans l'eau tout de suite je suis prêt
allez c'est parti let's go
W la M fa
là
ah son le tuyau ok alors voyons voir ce
qu'il y a une bouteille ouis
oui elle est
pleine
ouis tu peux la boir
avec ça sent quoi c'est Malibou non
c'est du sirop d'orja ou du Ricard c'est
de Laan
vous en voulez j'ai quelque chose
ok
nul
[Musique]
ah50 environ c'est un chien
percion
super voilà on voulait une arme
aujourd'hui on l'a faite ça y est ça y
est je
direct
super c'est cool très belle trouvaille
de notre ami Wim n'hésitez pas à aller
jeter un coup d'œil à sa chaîne qui sera
affiché
ici
ol
C on est motivé pour faire d'AES
armes
là une casserole
ok c'est pas
mal l'odeur est encore pire
ici
Xbox
dou radiateur bon on est de l'autre côté
du pont on espère trouver d' comme cell
des trucs d'époque va falloir creuser
bien dans la vase c'est
parti des morceaux de
métal morceau de pot d'échappement ça
vient oness de bien
éc ça pue un peu ça pu les
é de trouver biz
lasair super
[Rires]
tr
bra quand tuas un beau
tuette
est
ok 200 m ok c'est vraiment le bordel on
va nettoyer un peu les bouteilles et
tout
hein bonjour bonjour c'est la grand
pêche ouais c'est la grande pêche
par
ouais on vous le laisse là on le prendra
ouais je les poser là toute façon il
faut que je nettoie les mains à chaque
fois donc on les enlèvera POS
t'inquiète ah tu V
ouais alle
ok
fishing ah
oua oh il des trucs
intéressant
CP encore une fourchette j'ai même pas
vu elles sont propres cha
fois chose là W un autre
couteau de
couteau vous avez tout une
collection du
Dué c'est une
lamp
lampe une
serrure
wou encore un couteau
il est beau
ou il est joli
celuilà ah le couteau est sympa
ououp un couteau il est cassé
ouais
ouais dommage
oh purée ah ouais
joli c'est joli
ça J a cru j' a cru encore un qui c'est
qui s'énerve comme ça la
pêche
le
premier merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo de pêche à l'ément on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo peut-être en compagnie de
wi et Dan qui reste encore quelques
jours avec nous maintenant on va aller
se rincer dans la mer ouais on en a bien
besoin et encore une fois n'hésitez pas
vous avez la chaîne de Wim en
description de la
vidéo Tom j qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est rasta on va se
baigner on va se baigner on va dans la
mer tu es un copain en plus
[Rires]
il
m'embête al il est en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
forme să Go yeah